i'm so grateful for people like you to
be able to pull out of that i i've i've
been always the opposite
like
i've been very fortunate to just
always find joy meaning in everything
even the stupidest [ __ ] can i ask you
something yeah
do you think that's because you of
how you're raised where you came from
no
no it was my own person i i i honestly
think it's the the biology the the
uh this because i had my parents i'm
very cognizant of had nothing to
uh do with that they they never
understood this little engine i had i
just i always like just sitting looking
at people and just enjoying how amazing
they are and just like
looking at
like it's i think it's straight up just
biology whatever the neurochemistry is
like i'm just getting like a good drug
you're just getting hit yeah i'm getting
hit all the time from stupid [ __ ] and i
love that and it doesn't
and
yeah so that's why i can be sometimes
i'll talk like so very self-critically
about myself because that's almost makes
me
it makes life more fun it challenges
stuff he makes you more productive but
ultimately it's because i'm getting that
like
i'm getting the good stuff all the time
you